two and I'll call First in an emergency
they probably said Capaldi or something
like that Harry Styles seven percent
yeah I'd give Harry a hurry a show he's
um
he would give concrete advice good in an
emergency situation uh a relaxed figure
yeah I'm sure he would yeah you need
those yeah you need people like that
number two Lewis Capaldi ten percent
no he'd freako he he'd be more freaked
out than me
so I'm not giving him a shout
um yeah he would be he'd be all over the
place I'd have to go I'd actually have
to help it would work in Reverse I'd
call him and then I'd have to talk him
down
um yeah that's right number one let's
see what we got
his mom 43 yes I give my mother a shout
yeah although she'd probably freak out
too so not great ones